[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es in der wunsch torte ein
wunsch rezept ein nachgemacht videos von
mexiko ein einsatz kommt falsch das ist
falsche video
wir haben sagt so jetzt sind falsches
video ja ich weiß nicht was sie hatte
mit mexiko zu tun was soll der
schwachsinn der spd später lustig später
was machst du
ich machte nach macht sie großmacht sie
größer und breiter
so hätte ich ja die habe ich auch größer
und weitergegeben hat ich mache genau so
wie sie da ist original trifft sie aber
typisch deutsch wir jetzt größer breiter
mehr egal ich bin ja nur ein mexikaner
später im antrag ich mich ja beim
anderen medium so schnell
also heute machen wir die coppenrath &
wiese torte gemeinsam nach das ist die
hier aus dem tiefkühlfach und zwar die
sorte als es eine meister torte und die
sorte erdbeer frischkäse
sie haben sich viele gewünscht und ich
finde jetzt gerade zum valentinstag
passt jedoch ganz gut und ich sollte
vielleicht jetzt noch mal betonen ich
mache diese originale nicht nach umso
günstiger zu machen oder leckerer ich
mache einfach nur nach damit ihr wisst
wie man sie zum einen selber nachmachen
kann zum anderen schätzt man finde ich
auch die lebensmittel denn man weiß wie
viel arbeit darin steckt ich sehe jetzt
hier zum beispiel allein optisch vier
schichten den boden die erdbeer creme de
la creme und dann noch die frucht
schicht und preislich kommt er
eigentlich nie ans original rahmen es
wird immer teurer wenn ihr selber macht
denn die zutaten
ich kaufe dir doch mehr zutaten ein als
ihr für die torte braucht von daher also
es ist nicht der preis ist es auch nicht
der geschmack sondern einfach das selber
machen ja und natürlich spart man sich
wenn man die torte selber macht zu hause
oftmals auch konservierungsstoffe und
emulgatoren was man eben braucht wenn
man als unternehmen eine torte aus dem
tiefkühlfach anbietet das muss man
einfach machen damit die torte eben nach
dem auftritt frisch schmeckt und stabil
hält nicht runter läuft und das ist
jetzt auch nichts böses oder schlimmes
sondern es muss halt einfach technisch
so gemacht sein und deswegen ist es halt
so also heute gibt es diese torte ich
werde sie als ein objekt orte machen ich
habe es jetzt auch schon nach
packungsanleitung ausgepackt und auf
trauen lassen und schneidet jetzt mal an
ich probiert jetzt nämlich und dann
schauen softer am schnitt und dann werde
ich sie nach machen und euch einzelne
zeigen wo kann ich trotzdem an teller
bringen kam christian teller bringen
kannst wissen schlimmer machen weil ich
habe keine lust diesen beizutragen
da steht ja aber das recht ich frage
mich auch in bad essen und trinken kann
muss man auch sagen und aus dem heutigen
bei allen mexikanern entschuldigen die
sich jetzt bei unglaublich sehen das ist
ein typisch deutsches karnevalskostüm
und da werden stereotypen immer sowie
zeigen ich weiß dass in mexiko keiner so
rumläuft 100 prozent nicht
also ich meine mal probieren kunden
bereits auf ich mir gut gern richtig
erdbeere
ich muss ehrlich sagen das sieht finde
ich handgemacht aus opern stück also von
der mein gott also jetzt packe ich in
den kühlschrank und starrte mal mit dem
christina beck boden schossen mexiko
bringt torte hat 24 cm durchmesser und
ist knapp dreieinhalb zentimeter davon
ist ungefähr 0 6 cm boden also hole ich
jetzt butter für den knusper boden
brauche ich 170 km butterkekse 120 g
butter und etwas war lille extrakt es
kann jetzt zuerst die butter schmelzen
und die kekse dann einfach kurz
zerkleinern das geht wirklich super
einfach kriegt jeder hin
und die könnte entweder im mixer
zerkleinern oder eben mit dem ausbau
statt über eine gefriertruhe rollen
jetzt versuche ich die flüssige butter
mit den kerzen eine etwas größere
schüssel hätte auch gepasst und etwas
von den extrakt für den sally touch
jetzt alles gut verbunden ich nehme
jetzt einen trinken torten retter und
eine back folie habe es jetzt auf 24 cm
eingestellt da kommt jetzt die keks
mischung rein und dann flach drücken
entweder mit der hand oder mit der
bürger presse und dann den boden kurz
kühlen ich stelle den jetzt kurz ins
gefrierfach weil es einfach schneller
geht wir können es aber auch in den
kühlschrank stellen
für die creme brauche ich 150 gramm
tiefgefrorene erdbeeren etwas
zitronensaft 300 gramm fisch käse im
doppel rahm stufe 300 gramm sahne 50
gramm puderzucker etwas von extrakt sein
apparat und gefriergetrocknete erdbeeren
die erdbeeren werden jetzt fein gehackt
und kommen dann gemeinsam mit dem
zitronensaft in einen topf wo sie
eingekocht werden bis fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr vorhanden ist
so sieht es apple jetzt aus wie ich
lasse es jetzt schön abkühlen mache ich
ganz kurz im gefrierfach dann geht es
wirklich super schnell und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich hier schon mal die
creme vorbereiten
jetzt höre ich hier den frischkäse mit
dem puderzucker
da kommt direkt wandel extract dazu ich
versuche jetzt einfach eins zu eins die
cremes nachzubauen
jetzt kommt hier langsam die sahne dazu
jetzt ist alles geschmeidig verrührt und
jetzt nehme ich hier etwa drei esslöffel
raus das ist nämlich später für die deko
für die kleinen herzchen
da brauche ich etwas flüssigere creme
und der restliche creme schlage ich
jetzt mit seiner partei
jetzt die krieg steigt die zahl bei ich
sie kurz denn die eine hälfte wird ja
praktisch mit dem erdbeben vermischt
jetzt auch schon abgekühlt das muss
jetzt wirklich kalt sein sonst schmilzt
euch nämlich die sahne weg
jetzt kurz einrühren also in sachen
farbe habe ich die nase vorn und jetzt
nehme ich hier noch die
gefriergetrockneten erdbeeren wenn
gerade besser ist könnt ihr auch frische
erdbeeren nehmen gefrorene würden jetzt
hier drin einfach zu matschen und
wirklich flüssigkeit verlieren
gefriergetrocknet die sind ja schon
bereits trocken als wirklichen
unterschied zugefrorenen die sind
einfach ganz trocken
die idee mich jetzt hier mit ein
bisschen und die er für stückchen und
dann sind die nächsten zwei schichten
schon fertig also wirklich super einfach
dann kommt die f wie auf dem bild zuerst
den rosa schicht die sieht jetzt ein
bisschen weiches wahrscheinlich wegen
der master noch ich gebe jetzt doch noch
mal kurz ein teelöffel seiner partei zu
und jetzt schön glatt verteilen die
weiße creme habe ich übrigens sollen
jetzt im kühlschrank
jetzt frage ich die torte für etwa zehn
minuten ein und haben wir die schicht
schön fest und dann kommt die weiße
schicht darauf die weiße schicht darauf
auch schön glatt vorteil
die torte kommt jetzt noch mal kurz ins
gefrierfach und dann kann ich in der
zwischenzeit schon mal das kann ich
jetzt schon vorbereiten
die letzte schicht die erdschicht machen
geht noch superschnelle für die letzte
schicht braucht ihr nur noch drei
zutaten des werden zum einmal tief
gefrorene erdbeeren habe ich bereits
auftauen lassen etwas gaga als
pflanzliches geliermittel und etwas
zucker und ich gebe zu die erdbeeren
direkt in einen topf gibt es acker dazu
da stand sie noch ein bisschen und lass
dir dann aufkochen und zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen und je nachdem wie sich
die erdbeeren sind neben dir jetzt
zucker dazu oder eben nicht also da
müsste einfach mal probieren
ich werde jetzt noch parieren
[Musik]
zwei minuten muss noch nicht süß genug
also kommt jetzt der zucker mit dazu
trügen damit der sich auflöst und den
gebe ich jetzt aber erst wirklich zum
schluss dazu damit er nicht anbrennt am
topfboden okay und jetzt mache ich noch
kurze probe das heißt ich nehme einfach
hier einen esslöffel voll gibt es in ein
kleines schildchen stellt kurz in den
kühlschrank in der zeit kann die massen
hier auch schön lauwarm abkühlen und
nach einer minute etwas sehe ich auch
die masse fest wird oder nicht und ob
eben das engagiert oder nicht und falls
es noch nicht fest ist muss das noch mal
auf kochen mit etwas ärger und wenn es
fest wird ist es perfekt wie ihr sehen
könnt ist die probe schon fest geworden
und jetzt nehme ich hier diese übrige
creme die für die deko aufgehoben habe
die füllt jetzt einfach in einen
spritzbeutel oder in gefrierbeutel also
wirklich super easy kann jeder zu hause
nachmachen
ihr könnt auch wenn ihr habt so ein
kleines fläschchen nehmen aber das
braucht man echt nicht dass jetzt auch
verschließen und kurz zur seite stellt
jetzt müsste ein bisschen schnell
arbeiten damit das jetzt nicht verliert
während ihr doch noch kommentiert also
meine frau hätte jetzt hier drauf gießen
die schicht darf jetzt wieder zu kalt
sein noch zu warm wenn sie zu heiß ist
löst nämlich die sahne auf und wenn sie
kalt ist dann steht sie einfach zu
schnell verteilen
wenn wir da jetzt ein bisschen schüttelt
verteilt sie sich auch und jetzt ganz
schnell eine spitze wegschneiden es ist
mache ich ein zwei drei vier reihen und
lauter punkte hier rein
ich glaube wir zum bisschen und jetzt
mit einem schaschlikspieß hier
durchziehen
conditorei coppenrath & wiese gewinnt
das schönere herzchen den schöneren
herzchen contest ich habe so lange
gewartet mit mit der b probe aber alles
gut ich gebe die torte in den
kühlschrank
ich löste dann gleich raus und dann wird
probiert es war die halbe minute
minute
[Musik]
snowboard abgecheckt normalbetrieb kommt
jetzt auch so bist du jetzt auf linie
die gitarre stimmt ich hatte keine zeit
mehr
[Musik]
du musst mit einsätzen von mir geben
weil tochter die zwei frida kahlos ein
schöner schluss gar nicht mehr weg aus
unserer sicht ein fehler gemacht ich
wollte eigentlich dass von dem
coppenrath & wiese und von der unterlage
weg setzen aber man erkennt dass selbst
gemacht
ein bisschen herzen ja ich hab leider zu
lang gewartet ich wollte eben das zitat
das ist nicht schmilzt und jetzt war es
zu lange egal wir probieren jetzt das
geht jetzt erst einmal um den geschmack
wie gesagt nicht so lange mit der stadt
lehrprobe und mittelschicht aber so
finde ich ist eine schöne zeit dass ich
sehr schön die schichten also
optisch optisch kann man feststellen
dass sie ähnlich aussehen ja also hier
steht etwa schlecht bisschen dünner
auch von der masse hertener im hello
hello
also ich will bei mir ist schon bitter
so fruchtiger ich glaube dass man
darüber reden ob das da halt mehr echte
früchte drin sind und wer denke ich hier
ist einfach auch dünner und deswegen
eben auch heller ok max ist auch die
originale papieren die hast du schon
probiert über ja mit murat vorne nicht
schlecht ganz schön aus schnell lecker
ja ich gespannt ob er probierte
sie spielten der sportgeschichte
mehr erdbeeren und ich find's gut weil
es nicht so süß wie ich muss auch ein
also ich habe echt einen einzigen
kritikpunkt die torte schmeckt mir sehr
gut ich bin sie auch optisch echt schön
sieht auch finde ich sogar handmade aus
weil sie endlich so perfekt ist wie auf
dem foto ist die fotos sind wir echt
bisschen zu perfekt also eine fotoshow
ja aber ich kann zu entdecken zu süß
ansonsten schon schön frostig und
deswegen habe ich aber weniger zu kommen
ja ich will den job motor vom
zuckergehalt was mir hier besser
schmeckt ist die schicht oben die ich
noch bissl was man kann hier auch
bisschen weniger ager nehme ich nicht so
schnell mäßig stadt siebeneinhalb kam
vielleicht nur fünf gramm und dann
perfekt ich liebe auch den boden und ich
finde die torte extrem cool vor allem
jetzt zum valentinstag entweder zinslos
und holt euch eine kopie raten wie sie
das video übrigens nicht gesponsert ich
hab das rezept und ihn nachgemacht
dafür werde ich bezahlt aber muss auch
ehrlich sein und sagen wenn es einem gut
schmeckt aber für mich persönlich
schneller geht wenn ich die logik dort
einfach selber nach macht weil ich die
zutaten immer da hab und das auftauen
dauert auch extrem langen und so kann
ich selber bestimmen was drinsteckt und
die erdbeeren nehmen ja also wird es
auch selber machen viel spaß beim
nachmachen und schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare welches rezept welches
original ich als nächstes nach machen
soll bei nachgemacht auch regional
trifft charlie die wegnehmen das ist für
mich bestimmt keine augenbrauen
in brand mir hat es einmal meine
freundin weggebrannt brand im bunde
brenner im chemieunterricht und ein
friseur da war ich noch nie vorher
und die hat mir die in der mitte
komplett weg gezeigt da hatte ich
praktisch erst ab hier aber früher hat
man also ganz dünne gehabt zu sparen
drin
furchtbar leckere torten
[Musik]
jeder beweis dieser mann dieser mann er
hat den müll rausgebracht
er hat den müll rausgebracht